a U.S soldier crossed into North Korea
willfully and without authorization so a
United States soldier was in custody
actually uh in South Korea in a prison
he'd been held on assault charges and
was facing additional military
discipline and he was escorted to the
airport but instead of getting on his
flight he basically ran away he joined a
tour group with a group of civilians who
were going near the border he escaped
that tour group he ran into North Korea
and of course this creates a massive
diplomatic problem you know the United
States and North Korea are not in
contact with one another but of course
the United States government is going to
want to get this guy back what could he
have done that was so bad that he
thought he would be better off in North
Korea maybe he thought every woman look
like yomi Park and he thought he'd take
his chances this is something like that
I just I can't imagine I mean it's wild
it's it's insanely dangerous guy must
not have been thinking was he drunk
what's going on right now
I was gonna be like it's great that
you're here just tell us about your job
oh for sure let's hear what's going on
you know they are being very mean to you
that American Military we don't like
that at all actually Ian just raised a
perfect Point early 20s I do think that
might factor in because there's a lot of
danger tourism like one of the guys that
we work with in legacy's office Callum
um went over to Afghanistan so just
nodding his head uh he went over with
Lord miles and I don't know if anyone
knows but uh there was an update from
the Taliban today of Lord miles is still
being very politely very securely very
friendly held by the by the Taliban um
yeah so this might be a sort of danger
tourism thing of where he's going well
this looks like a crazy Place nobody's
been to maybe I'll try my luck I mean to
that to that end uh we should point out
that Otto one beer was the last uh high
profile at least he's not the the most
recent uh Americans have gone over but
uh he was a college student he had gone
over because he wanted to see the world
he wanted to be interesting and
apparently he stole a poster and got
held for years and years and ended up
dying that's right shortly after Trump
negotiated his return I think that he
said he someone in his church group
claimed that if he brought something
back that they would give him a car or
something wild like that and yeah so the
dude was sentenced to 10 years hard
labor if I'm not mistaken that might not
have been exactly but he ended up dying
before we could get him back yeah they
said it was botulism that killed him but
then there are reports actually there
was a North Korean defected spy defect
that had defected away from North Korea
the city was killed on he was poisoned I
mean he spent a long time in a coma
according to North Korea which they just
never updated anyone on I mean this is a
complete tragedy it's a very sad story
and I don't mean to make light of it but
uh this idea that we would have young
men who think oh well I'll just go to
North Korea I mean I don't think that
was necessarily Otto's uh motivation I
think there's probably something you
know very uh masculine and very
interesting and very real about wanting
to see dangerous places with this
American Soldier I really think we have
to question what is going on where you
think running across the border North
Korea is your answer right Paul of the
issue is America being on the world
stage now um not having president Trump
in office not having the same strong but
slightly strange relationship with
Little Rocket Man Kim Jong-un how are
you going to get him back yeah there's
no bargaining power to get this guy but
and any of the secrets that he might
know that's a pretty precarious
situation to be in because initially
when this story broke I thought you know
what is so bad that North Korea is the
answer but now you know you may be able
to live a nice life where North Korea
says thank you for all this information
for as long as they're willing to
tolerate you right I mean it's uh it's
it's a very bizarre story I have never
been in a position where I think I'd be
better off in North Korea lead in North
Korea yeah it's actually pretty
concerning on the macro scale like that
an American Soldier would defect to
North Korea of all places that's really
kind of freakish that is very freaking
what kind of lack of faith you would
have in your military to do that to
North Korea you know it hasn't before
has it yeah definitely is there people
fleeing charges like this this guy was
going to get charged with assault no I
don't think fleeing charges just people
that have left the military and cross
the border and then have been joined up
they use them I forgot his name was Ken
something like that they used him for
propaganda purposes for movies right I
guess yeah anywhere you won't be
extradited from it's somewhere like
North Korea yeah very true yeah um I
don't know you'd think people would
cross that border more often since
socialism works so well you know it's
actually interesting maybe he's just so
young that he was like I don't like the
American Military anymore and I really
think socialism is it so I'll just head
on over well I'm looking for places to
be to be refugees too because I was
talking to you guys about this off air
uh the UK government at the moment is
passing something called The Online
safety bill they used to call the online
homes bill so you know always always the
the loving kittens and puppies act and
and basically what it means is that it
puts the UK government's uh arbitration
body for television media that
stipulates you have to be unbiased
unless you left wing which you can get
away with it in charge of every internet
broadcaster so if you guys were
broadcasting in the UK from the UK not
just streaming in the UK then you would
have to have I don't know like all the
time as a guest to balance it out and it
would just just derail the conversation
of whatever topics you were doing and
and so like our show won't operate
especially because as well the possible
new prime minister wants to criminalize
misgendering so it's like am I going to
be I don't know crashing on a couch in
Tennessee in like a year's time who
knows I mean North Korea is looking real
Sunny this time of year
yeah I mean obviously they're not
they're not going to be the kind of
political Freedom we're looking for but
I hear you England is very scary right
now and this is something that a lot of
progressives neglect to acknowledge very
conveniently when they talk about the
kind of draconian speech codes that they
want to impose socially so they'll say
things like well these social media
companies might be censoring people but
it's done privately and like political
correctness or woke is about real
problems because it's all about just
being polite and being a different a um
excuse me respectful and decent person
of course in Europe people are actually
prosecuted for saying things that
challenge the regime that are considered
you know offensive that are harmful and
you know quote-unquote damaging to the
lgbtq community it's easy to forget this
as an American that in the Western World
there are people who are criminally
charged for saying things that fly in
the face of left-wing Orthodoxy there
are people who are criminally charged
for saying effectively men are men and
women are women and I'm not going to
call a man a woman or a woman a man and
there are people who cheer this on right
you'll get people who will say yes you
should absolutely pass that bill because
I don't want to hear these things and I
don't want other people to hear these
things I don't even know what you're
saying but I have heard are offensive
and that's what's the most disturbing to
me that we have a complete lack of
regards the fact that someone whose
opinion is different than you might not
be hateful right it's just different we
live in a culture that breeds fear which
begets compliance and I find that to be
so disturbing you're allowed to hate I
mean in the United States you're allowed
to hate it's totally cool as long as you
don't commit a crime you can hate all
you want I don't I don't like this hate
crime crap
like what is the how do you know what if
they had hate in their hearts sorry but
like since when did you murder someone
out of love yeah even even the crime of
passion is hatred in the moment so it's
it's completely nonsensical we've got
two pieces of legislation in the UK that
really screw us over um it's section 127
of the communications Act of 2003 that
means that if you say anything that can
be deemed quote grossly offensive over a
digital platform as long as they find
some someone who's offended by it or
even the case of count dankula they
couldn't but the the Scottish government
prosecuted him anyway
um you can be prosecuted for saying
something that offends someone and then
we also have the equalities act which
creates a sort of hierarchy of protected
characteristics and the frustrating
thing is and and this is why and I don't
wish to disparage um some of the turfs
even though I find the the label radical
feminists sends a shiver up my spine it
should yeah that's the only good
feminists in a lot of ways ah my well my
friend Mary Harrington and the
reactionary feminists would seem to
dissent on that point but I don't want
to get too derailed uh the the feminists
are using the equality act legislation
to fight the reason that they are being
prosecuted under the quality act so they
just got like gender critical beliefs
added to the equality act but it's like
you're just stacking more protected
characteristics on top of each other so
it's just going to be more absurd what
you need to do is jettison the protected
characteristics framework and have
something akin to an American First
Amendment except we don't have a Britain
Constitution because that's kind of
anathema to our country yeah you you
mentioned this thing uh also about the
the court system and in dankula and this
this case if I'm not mistaken wasn't the
uh opinion handed down that context
didn't matter yes that's unbelievable
that you could have a governing legal
Authority a judge say that context
doesn't matter he took it pretty much
every court that he could and they still
wouldn't take it context matters in an
example of that is like jaywalking if of
course it's illegal but if there's a
baby in the middle of the road and cars
coming you run out in the street and
grab the baby and take him to the
sidewalk you violated the law No One's
Gonna prosecute you for that all the
context matters I don't think exactly
it's even even illegal in the UK but but
maybe you're the land of the free yeah
yeah it's in every man for himself
um the the interesting thing though is
that we have abolished forgiveness and
Sheamus will agree with me on this when
we've become a post-christian culturally
we like to Pretend We're a
post-religious culture but they're just
a religion without metaphysic that's
right we we now have a one strike rule
that Brands you The Scarlet Letter
forever and the reason we do that as
well um is because we have met so many
of our material leads but now we have
moved on to the recognition economy this
is why there's so many information
sector jobs like social media or HR or
marketing and this is why the there's an
infinite number of fractionating Pride
Flags people want to codify their
personality type and demand that you
affirm them because their unsettled
screaming Consciousness their their
anxieties them doing something behind
closed doors that they know is kind of
sordid they need you to affirm them
exactly and at any time you don't it's a
transgression on their identity and so
it's akin to violence and that's the
situation We've Ended up in no that's
exactly what it is and I think you put
it perfectly there's screaming
consciences effectively when they see
you criticize them and in fact not even
necessarily just when they see you
criticizing them when they just see you
living and acting like a normal person
having a normal life and not engaged in
the degenerate nonsense that they're
engaged in they are bothered by it
because you in that moment are a proxy
for their conscience they see what they
could be so this idea that what I do
behind closed doors doesn't matter ah
yes of course your bedroom door has
magical properties such that it totally
erases the consequences of your actions
from your psyche and when you go into
the outside world your behavior is not
modified in the way you interact with
the rest of us is it modified or
effective by what you've done in there
it's nonsense yeah you need to create
that whatever whatever sort of thing
you're doing as being the new societal
standard so that you aren't tripping
around it like a Minefield in every
conversation you have and then you need
people to celebrate it so that it makes
you feel better about yourself because
just being accepted not being a special
little snowflake is not enough if you
have crippling social anxiety yeah I
think that's the important uh argument
for religion I think I know there are
criticisms of organized religion but
having something larger than yourself
means that you don't need to seek
affirmation from a crowd of people or
whoever's trendy right now whoever says
well I know how you can feel like you're
doing the right thing and we'll praise
you for doing this like it's such a
damaging way to live your life that I am
surprised that I'm not surprised because
our culture thrives on insecurity uh
it's funny to me that they can't look
themselves in the face and see oh I can
see that the cycle I'm trapped in I'm
ever good enough for this ideology that
actually hates me and would be fine if I
got destroyed because it betters their
own agenda yeah well and also oh sorry
I'll let you jump in a second because I
want to hear what you said that thinking
about that being people being used as
pawns to forward a political agenda like
if if uh what like someone that
identifies as a trans female is is goes
in into a shooting range and then is
killed by the police it's like oh Trans
rights you know and it's like what do
you mean the support they needed like
the justifications become insane because
we are willing to defy logic to protect
certain people if they fall into certain
certain ideological classes hey thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time